oh hi oh hello Kate I love the smell of
manure reminds me of my childhood that
poop oh yeah paint the best picture of a
horse whilst riding a horse you may only
paint when your horse is in motion so
wait a minute that means I have to ride
a horse yeah how's your horse riding
it's not good hoppy got you on the horse
why not make me strapped in strapped in
yeah I think so no let's do it
that's right a horse good luck oh thanks
now we're gonna see everyone except for
Freddie paint on a horse oh that's
excellent Alex how do you how do you
make the color brown God probably sees
Brown yeah you didn't give me brown your
painting evany there have any beautiful
name for a beautiful horse you enjoying
yourself Oh oh my god there we go
I bought them there we go that's the
horse pace you're not looking at the
model oh yeah yeah my bad how's your
fencing good that's good
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh I just peed
you guys know it's not easy the pain
little horse I'm never having children
now I mean I'm a natural that's looks
like a horse green one it's abstract
juice bag good thing that context cuz as
you know I freaking hate you yes before
you see the pictures like I should tell
you that Ron spent four times as long on
the horses anyone else no give me a free
horse ride I'm taking back
okay so strap yourselves in these are
the four horses I think Dylan did an
interesting job because it's kind of
like a transformers robot yeah soare
look at Ron's close-up beautiful yeah
what I noticed immediately it's like
you've just ordered a hamburger wrapper
but you looked at me like Oh kind of
looks like some kind of a animal of some
sort you get what I was it's very good
and very uh you could stop talking it's
a takes looks a bit like a horse which
is good okay yeah
[Applause]
and I'd like about Kate's is that some
of the pain is running off of the page
which indicates that it's bleeding into
our own reality which is interesting
there's one picture left as the weeping
horse of Lisa Lampanelli I like that her
and the horse have the same dye job
[Applause]